[Applaudissements]
et l'Oscar est décerné à Kiwi
[Musique]
dans Indiana Jones
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de l'école de cinéma de travailler comme
assistant réalisateur à plusieurs
reprises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
je viens de gagner un Oscar
mon parcours je l'ai commencé sur un
bateau j'ai passé un an dans un camp de
réfugiés et je sais pas trop comment
j'ai atterri ici sur la plus grande des
belles scènes d'Hollywood
[Applaudissements]
souvent on dit que ce genre d'histoire
elle n'écrit elle n'existe qu'au cinéma
et moi j'ai du mal à croire que ça
m'arrive à moi
c'est ça le rêve américain
[Applaudissements]
pour cette honneur merci à ma mère pour
tous les sacrifices qu'elle a fait pour
que je puisse être ici à mon petit frère
David
tous les jours juste pour me rappeler de
prendre soin de moi je t'aime mon frère
et tout ce que tu as fait merci H24
merci Daniel Jamie Michel
colonne mon frère à tout jamais
je dois tout à l'amour de ma vie ma
femme écho
OL qui moi après moi
depuis 20 ans me dit la même chose elle
me dit que un jour ce sera mon tour
j'ai failli abandonner les miens dans
toutes les personnes qui rêvent garder
ses rêves en tête ne les abandonnez
jamais
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci à l'Académie pour
cet accueil chaleureux je vous aime
[Applaudissements]